l'idée c'est pas de tirer sur une
ambulance à trois roues alors que là ça
commence à faire beaucoup mais moi je
suis quand même très étonné on découvre
pas ici le quoi le 18 janvier 2022 ce
que c'est que la symbolique en politique
oui personne ne découvre ce que c'est
que la symbolique en politique c'est à
dire que là en réalité on à la cerise
sur le gâteau d'une situation globale
qui est scandaleux c'est à dire que
depuis décembre on sait que le virus va
faire des dégâts considérables à l'école
il le sait jean michel blanquer puisque
de ce qu'on comprend quand il annonce au
gouvernement avant les vacances qu'il va
partir a émis sa visiblement on lui a
déconseillé donc tout le monde comprend
très bien ce qui se passe à la alors moi
j'ai envie de vous dire honnêtement si à
l'école depuis le 3 janvier les choses
s'étaient bien déroulés c'est à dire que
les revendications des personnels qui
sont remontés par les organisations
syndicales avaient été entendus si on
avait fait un effort sur les capteurs de
co2 sur les purificateurs d'air sur les
personnes aient reçu un truc vendredi ou
pain pour le monde n'a rien reçu moi
j'ai reçu j'ai des collègues qui
m'envoyaient des photos je vous jure la
tête des masques on a reçu c'est un truc
de fou c'est bien évidemment pas des
ffp2 mais c'est même pas des masques
avec élastique c'est des petites
ficelles qu'il faut attacher tant que
vous n'avez pas reçu des strings
tous les photos que m'a envoyé les
collègues c'est en plus envoyer dans des
sacs poubelle joue là sûr j'ai des
photos et donc en l'occurrence si tout
s'était bien déroulé mais je vous assure
il serait parti à la guerre point qu il
serait parti à ibiza ou à saint tropez
nous ce qui nous ce qui aurait été
important pour nous c'est comment ça se
serait déroulé professionnellement il se
trouve que c'est un bordel sans nom et
quand et dont on a eu le 13 janvier vous
vous souvenez de mon petit duo
sympathique avec madame elle a écrit le
13 janvier on a une journée de
mobilisation massive bas est derrière
nous on apprend ça mais comment voulez
vous que ce ne soit pas du point de vue
chez les enseignants quelque chose de
totalement enfin il ya une attitude de
scandale surtout que quand même bon
alors ça fait deux fois que jean michel
leblanc caire fait un mea culpa quand on
connaît le personnage ça fait beaucoup
ça veut dire que lui même comprend bien
que la situation est grave mais ce qu'il
dit en sortant avec un air contrit sur
le perron du ministère de l'éducation
nationale c'est complètement insuffisant
ils nous envoient quelques quelques
masques ffp2 bien du point de vue des
personnels il nous dit qu'il ne dégage
des moyens qui ne sont pas des moyens
pérennes c'est à dire en gros c'est des
moyens provisoires des retraités à qui
on demande dans des clusters c'est un
peu périlleux à qui on demande de venir
faire des remplacements des gens qui ne
sont pas encore formés faut juste
rappeler que depuis que monsieur blanc
caire et ministre de l'éducation
nationale on à supprimer 8000 postes
d'enseignants dans l'éducation nationale
les faits sont têtus pour revenir à ça
et donc quand on a à côté des
enseignants qui continue à être parmi
les moins bien payés de l' ocde et bien
quand on apprend que effectivement au
lieu de bosser à fond sur le protocole
et ben ils étaient encore jusqu'au 2
janvier avec ses tongs à ibiza
excusez-nous ça pose problème alors
c'est du symbole certains vous diront
non il était en télétravail mais c'est
n'importe quoi on est dans le symbole en
politique et personne n'ignore ce que
c'est que le symbole en politique c'est
alors vous vous pensez qu'on en fait
trop valérie venez non mais j'entends
évidemment le symbole c'est hyper
important est évidemment que le
marketing en politique ça compte et d'où
l'on parle ça compte et en l'occurrence
la veille d'une crise majeure parce que
la rentrée des classes était là et que
savoir après que le que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale étaient en lice a
en plus la ville elle-même était
symbolique
énormément évidemment que ça va
réveiller les opposants et il a bien
compris ce que ce qui m'a ce qui
m'interpelle moi c'est que je suis
d'accord c'est une connerie je suis
d'accord c'est une boulette je suis
d'accord c'est une maladresse tout ce
qu'on veut après on peut croire ou pas
croire que ce que ce se munissent de
l'éducation est au front et travaille
bien ou pas bien chacun y verra ce qu'il
a envie d'y voir en revanche moi je
trouve que là pourquoi on en fait
beaucoup c'est parce que la campagne a
démarré et que l'on est en plein dans la
campagne voilà pour le coup il ya aussi
une opposition qui fait c'est un plan
car bashing parce que la tête d'alex et
mourra qui a défendu jean michel guy
hoquet et c'est une façon d'atteindre
d'atteindre d'atteindre le président qui
n'est pas encore candidat et comme
justement le président emmanuel macron
quand il au sérieux la faire selon
mediapart le comportement de jean michel
bancaire et ce retour tardif tardif de
l'île d'ibiza a provoqué de vives
tensions au sein même du gouvernement
les enseignants ont besoin d'être aimés
alors que blanc caire a quitté
symboliquement son ministère un collègue
ma chronique de jean michel blanquer
remet emmanuel macron préfère ne pas
réagir et se tenir à distance des
polémiques l'elysée n'a souhaité faire
aucun commentaire en terme et la semaine
dernière en pleine tempête le président
avait remercié le ministre pour jocistes
je cite sa mobilisation de qui lui a
renouvelé sa confiance juste oui il faut
être précis parce qu'il ya quand même
une déclaration d' emmanuel macron ya
pas longtemps lassés je pense que
j'étais il ya une dizaine de jours où il
disait ouvertement qu effectivement un
protocole sanitaire qui tombe le 2
janvier c'est totalement
ça laisse très peu de temps au rectorat
pour s'organiser disait-il quand on sait
qu'en fait eh ben le 2 janvier jean
michel blanquer air est encore sur son
lieu de villégiature à ibiza forcément
quand même ça prend une connotation
particulière tout ça moi j'aimerais bien
avoir effectivement une déclaration de
monsieur castex pour savoir vu qu'il
était au courant et qu'il a déconseillé
semble-t-il au ministre de l'éducation
partir qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de ça